un ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin recevais en fin de journée et
syndicats et associations de policiers
la police confronté à une vague de
suicides dans ses rangs depuis le début
de l'année douze policiers se sont donné
la mort en france le problème date pas
d'hier les causes sont multiples les
profils différents et les syndicats
alertent depuis des années sur ce
phénomène dramatique
on en parle avec pierre cabaret chez
députés et la république en marche en
haute-garonne et as dit mme tarby maire
un pcf de stands soutien de jean-luc
mélenchon
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france has been
taibi ce fléau des suicides dans la
police même si on le rappelle toutes les
histoires personnelles sont très
différentes les unes des autres est-ce
qu'il est quand même aussi le symbole
d'un mal être au sein de la profession
will est évidemment c'est un bol d'un
mal être qui malheureusement ne date pas
d'hier on sait déjà depuis
malheureusement depuis de très
nombreuses années que nous assistons à
manage assez profond je dirais à
désarroi de beaucoup de policiers et
permettez moi quand même d'avoir une
pensée très émue auprès des familles des
douze policiers c'est énorme depuis des
mois de janvier la disparition de douze
policiers
suicide c'est énorme donc souvent les
suicides ont lieu ce soir dans leur lieu
je dirais personnel familial peut-être
certains hauts lieux au moment d'aller
au travail ou pas donc il ya vraiment il
ya véritablement un malaise il ya un
malaise qui est à la fois je dirais
qui est clairement de montrer que la
police l'institution policière ne
protège pas assez poussé policiers et
psychologiquement mais également sur une
démarche je dirais beaucoup plus
collectif beaucoup plus je dirais
rassurante
et forcément c'est c'est cette
disparition terrible
doit en tous les cas nous rappeler qu'il
ya nécessité de mon point de vue a au
fond des je dirais bien sédiments dans
les grands axes
trop polis de la république c'est une
police républicaine une police qui est
au service
des citoyennes et des citoyens de ce
pays et on a bien spur bien évidemment
besoin de cette police le policier
proche de nos populations en particulier
dans les zones où nous manquons
cruellement de policier c'est le cas ici
instinct a été largement
seine-saint-denis donc donc voilà donc
face à ceux à cette situation générée
insoutenable humainement est extrêmement
difficile à la fois pour les familles
des policiers décédés mais également
pour tous les policiers qui travaillent
sur le terrain et qui sont confrontés à
beaucoup de difficultés et parfois on
leur demande de faire du chiffre on leur
demande
d'atteindre des objectifs qui sont
parfois il réalisable parce que parce
que la police a besoin
a besoin de travailler dans la durée a
besoin de travailler aussi avec des
missions beaucoup plus large qui ne sont
pas que des missions de sécurité et
garantir la sûreté de nos concitoyens
même si c'est important mais elle a
besoin aussi travaillé dans le domaine
de la prévention au travail dans le
domaine aussi je dirais de la relation
avec les sites où justement pierre
cabaret qu'elle annonçait ce qu'on peut
attendre ce soir du ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'entretient donc
visiblement toujours avec associations
et syndicats de policiers qu est ce qui
a été fait au cours de ce quinquennat
aussi pour accompagner ces policiers
dans l'exercice de leur profession
bonsoir vous me permettrez d'abord de
présenter toutes mes condoléances à la
fois aux familles et à chaque policier
aussi parce que il ne faut pas oublier
que chaque policier qui décède et
entouré et a été entouré par ses
collègues donc
je d'abord il a été fait énormément de
choses et dernièrement encore on a
renforcé à la fois le matériel à la fois
le la reconnaissance salariale mais ce
sont des personnes qui effectivement
manque de reconnaissance je crois que
lorsque on a une population qui peut
passer de l'applaudissement à dire les
violences policières et quand j'entends
le maire de stains vous permettrait
monsieur le maire être très étonnée par
votre demande alors que pendant très
longtemps vous avez vous même exprimer
ces violences policières de façon
déraisonnée parce que pour moi elle y
est et déraisonné cette expression et
déraisonné voilà donc la première chose
deuxième chose je crois que depuis cinq
ans il ya eu une prison ou charger une
frère en conscience de du mal être de la
police c'est très compliqué de répondre
de façon
immédiate mais les psychologues qui sont
là il y en a 120 aujourd'hui on aura
d'autres prochainement
sont là pour recueillir leurs leur mal
être et comment alors je vais je veux
dire je commençais un policier pour
exprimer son mal être auprès de sa
famille mon fils a été policier pendant
onze ans et c'est vrai qu'il a commencé
à 22 ans
c'est très très difficile
ils vivent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles parce qu'il voit
la misère ils voient la mort il voit
tout ce qui dans notre société est
terriblement difficile de se représenter
et en plus quand on a 22 ans et ils me
racontaient ce qu'ils voyaient elvi il
avait quand même c'est un exutoire de
raconter à son père en tout cas ses
parents ce qu'ils voyaient un policier
quand il a une trentaine d'années qui
hantent il rentre chez lui quand il à
ses enfants quand ses enfants eux mêmes
ne disent pas à l'école que son papa et
policiers parce que finalement à l'école
on dénigre beaucoup les policiers aussi
et auront qu'on essaie de cacher le
métier bien acquis va-t-il le dire sinon
à ses collègues et je crois que
là-dessus c'est très important que ses
collègues puissent recueillir ces
paroles et de façon un peu plus forte et
que les syndicats soient plus
directement concernés par tout cela et
je crois que on à frédéric veaux qui est
très compétent on a un ministère de
l'intérieur qui est extrêmement objectif
là dessus qui prend des décisions qui
scellait qui sait faire des choix et je
pense que à l'issue de ces réunions on
va avoir des annonces n'ont pas des
annonces mais des actes parce que vous
savez on peut toujours pas faire les
paroles mais la politique en ai plein le
plein de parole donc maintenant il faut
des actes je voudrais souligner aussi
que
les élus ont un rôle extrêmement
important moi je je ne lâche pas les
policiers je ne les ai jamais lâché je
vais les verts rencontrer régulièrement
je vais avec eux régulièrement et ça va
de la ronde à l'apéritif avec eux et on
apprend beaucoup de choses et vous savez
on apprend tellement de choses qu'on a
envie de les recevoir l'assemblée et 7
et les recevoir l'assemblée c'est
peut-être pas pour recevoir toujours
gelé plus haut gradé qui vont nous
raconter et nous dire leur vie et c'est
important aussi que de les recevoir mais
aussi laisser la place à ceux qui sont
dans la rue ou dans les bureaux qui
reçoivent les personnes qui sont dans la
détresse et je crois que là-dessus
j'aimerais proposer à l'assemblée
nationale prochainement de pouvoir
recevoir de façon anonyme
ces policiers pour qu'ils nous racontent
leur vécu et qu'on puisse nous aussi élu
pouvoir réagir de façon très positive
assez assez désespoir de personnes voilà
donc nul doute que voilà on va faire
réagir à azim taibi à ces propos que
vous venez d'entendre sur les relations
entre les élus et la et la police au
quotidien elle elle est comment elle
elle ressemble à quoi as tu un dans
votre commune
eh ben elle est concrète en jeu les
rencontres quasiment tous les jours que
ce soit une réunion mensuelle avec le
commissaire ça peut peut-être surprendre
monsieur cabaret quand je vais rebondir
après sur la question des drames sion et
sierre et puis sur la question si des
moyens que je réclame depuis de très
nombreuses années pour qui beaucoup plus
de moyens de police asta on va faire
d'égalité j'ai tenu au
bas mot pour nous moquons de policiers
déjà donc certainement que monsieur
cabaret et tout savoir il ya eu un
rapport extrêmement intéressant pour pas
les menteurs d'ailleurs qu'il a été
rédigé par un de vos impôts un de vos
collègues le rapport qui met en lumière
je dirais l'échec de la république en
seine-saint-denis en matière de en
matière de sécurité en matière de
justice
et en matière d'éducation or je vous
rassure c'est échec en matière de
sécurité ne date pas depuis l'arrivée de
maquereaux il faut être raisonnable et
même malheureusement le sait s'est
aggravée elle d'elle depuis qu' un
certain président sarkozy a décidé je
dirais de supprimer des milliers de
postes avec sa politique de les gérer
j'ai payé c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné il a supprimé des postes au sein
des différents services publics des
corps constitués que ce soit la police
ou la gendarmerie et ça a été fatale
pour des villes comme star pour des
villes populaires je pense que c'est
certainement aussi le cas en province
avec la gendarmerie dont qu'on a on a
payé très cher ici à stains je dirais le
fait qu'ils aient passé de policiers
n'ont pas à ses policiers il faut aussi
les policiers extrêmement formé par les
policiers sont formés en quelques mois
alors que parfois il faut des cursus de
formation qui soit beaucoup plus long et
qui soit aussi adapté aux réalités du
territoire donc à côté de ça moi j'ai
aucun souci travaille avec la police
mais je le fais au quotidien que ce soit
avec mon commissaire avec les réunions
mensuelles que ce soit avec le
commandant du commissariat ou avec les
agents de la police je rappelle que j'ai
une police municipale aussi à 7 ans et
nos politiques et la police municipale
et la police nationale travaillent je
verrai en total intelligence en symbiose
ensemble et ça ne m'empêche pas en effet
deux aussi de me le dire est de me lever
face aux violences policières qui
existent et qui sont le fait de certains
policiers jeu précis de pâtes ou les
policiers ça existe tout comme je me
lève face aux violences qui peuvent
exister dans les quartiers à l'encontre
des policiers je suis bien placé pour
savoir parce qu avant d'émerger des
éducateurs et je travaille sur les
quartiers et j'ai passé mon temps j'ai
passé 20 ans de ma vie professionnelle à
créer les conditions
d'apaisement à j'étais un petit peu le
ventre les autres les deux le pompier un
peu de papier le service pour calmer et
d'un côté les jeunes qui vont en
découdre avec la police y est avec les
policiers suite à des contrôles suite à
deux choses et puis d'un autre côté avec
certains policiers ont leur vie dans le
calme et vous il faut discuter et cetera
donc quand je parle de refondation enfin
en tous les cas de réformer la police et
la police c'est justement de faire en
sorte que la police soit un sujet je
dirais partager un objet politique
partagée
en effet par les institutions que
représente la police mais aussi par la
population je pense que c'est important
les élus et vous l'avez dit monsieur
monsieur cabaret les élus ont un rôle
majeur à jouer là dessus les élus les
associations les différentes forces
vives qui sont sur le terrain pour
justement les syndicats bien évidemment
mais pas que les syndicats et d'ailleurs
tous les syndicats il faudra y est je
pense que même il faudrait certainement
arrêter d'écouter que certains
représentants de syndicats qui donc
n'ont qu'une j'ai bien une ambition
c'est de mettre la pression sur les
gouvernements qui se sont succédé et en
particulier sur les ministres de
l'intérieur pour leur dicter un petit
peu la loi une orientation politique à
l'échelle gouvernementale
vous faites allusion j'imagine au grand
oral qui s'est tenue mercredi
policiers alliance et trois candidats
marine le pen eric zemmour on rappelle
que les candidats de gauche ont décliné
l'invitation jean luc mélenchon lui n'a
pas été invité pierre cabaret justement
au cours de ces échanges est revenu à
plusieurs reprises ce lien qu'ont fait
certains de candidats entre
police
et justice il est revenu aussi cette
expression de violence policière vous en
parliez tout à l'heure vous l'a décriée
ainsi jeu j'ai bien compris vous ce
couple pourtant emmanuel macron lui même
avait admis et repris cette expression
de violence policière il a eu tort
je pense que il a repris l'expression
dans le sang de violence de certains
policiers ce que l'on peut concevoir
aussi et il y a eu des violences
certainement de certains policiers comme
il ya des abus dans chaque profession et
on le voit bien aujourd'hui y compris
dans les ehpad mais donc
cette cette image de violences
policières qui concernerait chaque
policiers dans les manifestations
et qu'ils soient qu'ils soient le
traitement dure vis-à-vis d'un et est
extrêmement injuste vis-à-vis d'une
population moi j'adore charest oui
effectivement j'ai décrit donc mais moi
j'en fais pas une affaire politique
surtout parce que la politique les gens
en ont ras le bol vous savez ce qu'ils
veulent ce sont des ce sont des actes si
les parents
justement sur sa campagne présidentielle
c'est la sécurité quel bilan est ce que
voudraient se rayer du quinquennat
macron
je pense que c'est un bilan qui évolue
vers le mieux donc déjà c'est un déjà
c'est une bonne chose ensuite c'est une
un bilan qui évolue vers la prise en
charge de chacun donc qui peut
s'exprimer et qui doit s'exprimer
ensuite j'entendais tout à l'heure
monsieur monsieur le maire qui disait la
formation quelques mois non monsieur le
maire la formation d'un policier d'un
policier national c'est une année et je
reconnais qu effectivement il faut
mettre l'accent sur cette formation
continue mais cette formation continue
il faut mettre l'accent aussi sur le
fait de pouvoir partager continuellement
cette expérience et y compris les plus
douloureuses au sein du groupe et ça je
crois c'est une action c'est une des
volontés du gouvernement actuellement
c'est une volonté de de monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur de pouvoir
objective et c'est ces choses là non pas
directement vers toujours les
psychologues mais mes verres aussi
l'ensemble des collègues aujourd'hui le
lien si la chose la plus important si ça
la chose qui doit rassembler mais ça la
chose qui doit aider et protéger si le
lien ce lien là il faut le retrouver il
faut retrouver ce lien dans la police
mais ils furent occupées ce lien entre
la police et aussi la population et il
ne faut pas négliger aussi qu' il ya
certaines populations qui ont une haine
de la police et il faut revendiquer que
ces populations kyste être punis
lorsqu'ils pratiquent ce genre de choses
parce que ça n'aide personne et ça
n'aide surtout pas les policiers dans
leur travail et ni la justice dont le
sien aussi et je ne poserai pas la
police et la justice alors sur ce point
du lien nécessaire entre la police et sa
population je pense que vous êtes en
face al din taibi avec ce qui vient
d'être d'être dit quelles sont les
grandes propositions de votre candidat
jean-luc mélenchon c'est sur ce thème de
la mobilité sera le mot de la fin
avant de vous faire part des grandes
propositions proposée par jean luc
mélenchon et par le programme à venir en
commun d'abord il faut pour répondre à
monsieur cabaret il faut savoir que
celles et ceux en tout cas ce qui
des postures de haine violente par la
police sont je dirais sont directement
jugé en tant que je ne faisais pas
croire que ne faites pas croire
justement que c est ce qui me liront des
comportements violents ou haineux envers
la police ne sont pas forcément jouer
ils sont jugés et même très très
sévèrement jugés risqués ce qui
malheureusement n'est pas toujours le
cas ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
dans ce sens inverse pour pour pour des
policiers maintenant dans les grandes
propositions dans les grands axes
communs que propose jean luc mélenchon
et pour lequel on a été très nombreux à
travailler d'abord le retour une police
de proximité ça c'est extrêmement
important je pense que là je dirais
l'efficacité de la bac de la ligne
paris-bâle anti criminalité
à je dirais et plus qu'on est plus que
j'étais dans une situation d souplement
moi je vois sur ma vie les cinq
territoires seine saint denis donc il
faut passer de mon point de vue à une
police vraiment de proximité des agents
qui sont prêts sur le terrain
sont outillés qui sont à je dirais
équipés pour travailler sur le terrain
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose qui me semble tellement importante
je rejoins monsieur cabaret c'est de
créer toutes les conditions pour
vraiment tisser du lien très fort entre
les usagers entre les citoyens et la
police l'autre point important de mon
point de vue et jean luc mélenchon l'a
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises ces
abroger toutes les lois sécuritaires qui
n'ont eu aucune efficacité si ce n'est
de créer encore plus je dirais densité
et confusion entre le est sécuritaire
qui parfois se confondent avec des lois
je dirais contre le terrorisme et c'est
donc on est très vite dans un
bascule très vite dans un terrain qui en
réalité n'est pas la preuve qu'il n'est
pas là n'est pas la préoccupation
première en matière de sécurité mais
plutôt une préoccupation de stigmatiser
plus de populations de différents
quartiers bon je pense que toutes les
lois sécuritaires et je sais que le
président m'a qu'on ne les partage pas
forcément je serais assez surpris que le
présent mac on partage les lois
sécuritaires qui ont été ainsi jédir est
mise en place à l'époque de de sarkozy
hortefeux dauchez pas sûr et puis un
autre un autre élément important c'est
en effet de complètement référent
réformer
l'igpn parce qu'il faut en tous les cas
dans toutes les enquêtes je virais de de
violences policières dans toutes les
enquêtes et permettez moi de vous dire
que je vois pas trop de différence entre
environ policière et violences de
policiers il n'y a pas de voeux la plume
quand on parle de notre policière ça ne
crie pas tous les policiers 5,6
milliards d'encours ici et je voulais
l'igpn
dit gpn de mon point de vue doit être
remplacée par une institution totalement
indépendante qui doit être en tous les
cas complètement indépendante et pas
forcément sous le sous la sous la
coupelle d'autres aux policiers pour
qu'elle puisse en tous les cas mené
jusqu'au bout son travail tant qu est
son travail je dirais deux façons
de façon indépendante pour qu'ensuite et
du mexique se prononcer beaucoup
évidemment on aura l'occasion de revenir
en détail sur ses propositions en
matière de sécurité tout au long de
cette campagne présidentielle merci à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à cet
échange est d'une taille billère 1 pcf
de ce temps soutient jean luc mélenchon
merci à vous
pierre un cabaret députés à la
république en marchant en haute garonne
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis